il est 7h30 un vendredi de mai nathalie
beaulieu nous entraîne presque au pas de
course dans les couloirs de l'édifice
qui abrite les bureaux de la direction
de la santé publique de la
capitale-nationale
c'est ici que ça se passe et c'est elle
la chef d'orchestre at elle évolué je
suis comme un prêt sans prévention et
protection des maladies infectieuses à
la direction de santé publique fait
refaire ça ne pandémie je vous dirai
pour une coordonnatrice c'est comme
faire du sol
il faut vraiment toujours ajuster les
ressources humaines la méthode de
travail et tout change tout le temps
premier arrêt la salle des enquêtes
c'est ici que se portent les engueule
complètement tout ce qui est fait auprès
des clients les croix positif
l'évaluation lankais clé questionnaire
de téléphone
moi je sors positif on va aussi par
l'afflux proférées l'écho et croit vous
avez été testés pour la corvée 19
votre résultat arrive ici par
télécopieur si votre test est positif
vous ferez l'objet d'une enquête le on
s'entend que vous avez été en contact
avec des collègues de travail
puis vous avez seulement travaillé à
l'hôtel du québec puis au jardin de
manger lieu dans les 14 jours
je l'équipe d'un câble du jour une
équipe qui reste d'habitants une équipe
qui rentabilité donc c'est le caucus
dans le fond de début de journée là pour
un peu orienté de nos actions 24 dans la
journée il ya eu quand même du dépistage
de masse ce qui s'est fait dans certains
milieux donc je sais que ça va être une
bonne journée aujourd'hui au niveau des
enquêtes
isabelle beaulieu gère les enquêtes et
travaillent en collaboration avec
nathalie beaulieu le duo polluer
beaulieu est au front depuis le début de
l'éclosion
moi je m'appelle isabelle beaulieu je
suis chef de service à la direction de
santé publique en prévention et
protection des maladies infectieuses
on a les dossiers orange que pour nous
c'est l'écho positif et les dossiers
gens c'est l'écho associée aux cas
positifs le d'ordre à la recherche de
contacts donc le conjoint et les enfants
d'autres travailleurs dans le même lieu
à qui on doit faire des suivis en deux
mois dans la capitale nationale 3360 ans
qui a été piqué myologie qu'ont été
réalisée à la mi mai on comptait 1310
cas positifs compilées dans ces dossiers
orange et 2050 dossier jaune ceux des
personnes qui ont été en contact avec
des cas positifs pour arriver à mener
des enquêtes en dedans d'une douzaine
d'heures il a fallu faire passer le
nombre d'infirmières enquêtrice de 3 à
30 et avec le déconfinement on estime
qu'il en faudra encore une vingtaine de
plus michel gagné et dominique poirier
sont du nombre
bonjour c'est michel gagné les premières
encore la santé publique
alors est-ce que vous avez rejoint votre
conjoint pour penser à tout fort recul
en arrière
allez voir ce qu'ils ont fait mais nuit
une ouïe et ayons chez eux
il faut savoir oublier terre en fait une
enquête des fois c'est fini parce que
dans la maison ils sont six
alors lisez il faut évaluer tout le
monde ben bella jeanne en fac est malade
mais je le déclare positif alors c'était
notre enquête
pour les autres des doux aussi de
contacter leur vient d'apprendre la
milda
80 et quelques années qui est positive
mais qu' aucun symptôme
alors ça a créé énormément d'anxiété
quand ils apprennent qu'ils sont
positives parce qu'ils croient que là
ils vont peut-être mourir ou se demande
qu'est ce qui va se passer et comment ça
j'ai pas de symptômes mais ce que je
vais en avoir des faux faut leur donner
un peu de temps parce qu'il pleuve ou de
téléphone à lyon par des conséquences si
on parle des effets de la cua vide
il ya des gens qui ont des facteurs de
risques importants
c'est sûr que parfois ça peut amener un
peu de détresse psychologique un faut
prendre le temps de bien lui annoncer qu
est ce que ça implique ce diagnostic
l'eau les mesures à prendre pour éviter
la propagation éviter la propagation de
la kobe 19
c'est le but de ces équipes pisté les
malades et leurs contacts
les isoler mais dans certains milieux la
coved 19 s'est propagé les couleurs
mardi se sont employés aussi l'usagé on
y voit par milieu on voit par milieu nos
éclosion et on est capable de suivre
paraît être deuxième étape de cette
visite la salle où sont documentées les
éclosions nathalie nous parle du
jefferies le milieu le plus touché par
la coved 19 à québec ici paraît pages on
voit on voit les quoi arriver qu'est ce
qu'on a mis comme the hélas ici dans cet
âge là il ya encore des causes qui on a
perdu pourquoi alors là on va rechercher
analyser qu'elle soit en intervention
spécifique parce que l'espace quelque
chose de transmission un cas type nos
livres des logiques sont quoi et c'est
sûr vous allez voir les médecins
spécialistes la gaine de médecins coved
ici vont travailler à analyser réfléchir
ceux qui réfléchissent aux moyens de
contrer ces éclosions se réunissent en
ligne chaque jour ils sont 32 ce matin
ces rencontres virtuelles sont
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
situation et de mettre en place des
solutions
nathalie beaulieu nous explique que la
région comme la province sont mobilisés
depuis la mi janvier pour se préparer à
cette crise
le 21 janvier les urgences des hôpitaux
ont relevé leur niveau d'alerté en lien
avec les voyageurs malades
le 23 janvier la sécurité civile s'est
associé à la santé publique pour
préparer la gestion de la crise
le 24 janvier la région fait face un
premier cas probable dans une urgence
on a eu tout de suite en quelques heures
après la mise en place de ces mesures là
quelqu'un qui se présentent avec des
symptômes et qui répondait directement
aux critères ont déroulé le tapis en
marche et en même pas déçu là c'est ça
qu'on faisait
on n'avait pas les outils on n'avait pas
les questionnaires enquête on n'avait
pas non plus notre trajectoire de
comment roger rey échos et 3 le red star
le test du voyageurs revenant de one
s'est avéré négatif
mais le signal était lancée il fallait
vite mettre en place des stratégies
réunir le plus de personnel possible et
faire face à la situation
nathalie a réussi à rassembler une
centaine d'employés
depuis tous sont réunis ici est
concentré sur un seul objectif la lutte
à la coved 19 ici ghislaine bussy à
radio canada québec